ساحة المعركة الأجنبية في شرق أوكرانيا تظهر نداء يائس للمساعدة حيث
تناشد امرأة أوكرانية من أجل لقطات حياة زوجها الجريح
من يونيو الماضي ، اللحظة
التي اتخذ فيها زوجان أوكرانيان
منعطفًا خاطئًا نحو خط أمامي نشط
تعرضت سيارتهما لإطلاق نار من القوات الروسية القريبة
بشدة.  جرحت زوج السائق فاليريا
باناميروفا ،
رأيت رأسه مصابًا
وبدأت على الفور في ضم رأسه ، حيث تم
تصوير الحادث على شريط فيديو بواسطة
طائرة بدون طيار يقودها جنود أوكرانيون
وتم تجميعها لاحقًا في فيلم وثائقي للمخرج الأوكراني لوبامير ليفيتسكي.  وصرخت فقط
بأشد صرخة مؤلمة
لم أكن أعرف من هي الطائرة بدون طيار
قواتنا أو العدو ، قام
الطيار بتسجيل لافتة تقول اتبعني
على طائرته بدون طيار ووجهت باناميروفا إلى
بر الأمان ، فقد اتخذت القرار المؤلم
بترك زوجها الجريح وراءها.
تابعت طائرات الدرون الروسية التي
خرجت للاقتراب من سيارتها ،
فأخذوا زوجها أندريه وألقوا
به في حفرة ،
هذا هو التقاطع الذي
وقع فيه إطلاق النار الرهيب في يونيو ،
ثم حرر الجيش الأوكراني
المنطقة مما سمح
للشرطة الأوكرانية بالدخول وإطلاق صاروخ.
قال محققو الشرطة الأوكرانية في التحقيق في جريمة حرب روسية مزعومة إنه قال بلفينوف إنه جمع
أدلة لاتهام ضابط روسي يبلغ من العمر 26 عامًا بارتكاب
جريمة حرب
بمحاولة قتل مدني ،
وهو قائد سرية في
فرقة البنادق الآلية الثانية.  أول دبابة تابعة للجيش في
المنطقة العسكرية الغربية ، أنشأنا
هويته
للشرطة للعمل هنا ،
كان على خبراء المتفجرات أولاً تطهير منطقة الألغام الأرضية
ثم أجرت الشرطة تحليلًا للطب الشرعي
والباليستي لمسرح الجريمة
تقول الشرطة الأوكرانية إن القوات الروسية
كانت متمركزة هنا على هذا الجانب من هذا
الجدار  ومن هنا أطلقوا
النار على مفتش السيارات بوليفيا ، يظهر
لي ما يقول إنه
اعتراضات هاتفية تجرم
المشتبه به الرئيسي الذي اتصل بزوجته
الأجنبية
مم همم أم أوه
نعم
تقول الشرطة الأوكرانية أن السلاح كان
مدفعًا عيار 30 ملم على متن هذا النوع من
قالت شرطة مركبات المشاة القتالية
إنها تتبعت أيضًا صور
الضابط وزوجته من
حساباتهم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في ذلك اليوم المظلم ،
تابعت فاليريا باناميروفا الطائرة بدون طيار إلى بر الأمان وهي
تتجول حول الألغام الأرضية القاتلة حتى
قابلها جندي أوكراني ، كان الأمر
خطيرًا جدًا على القوات.  لاستعادة أندريه
جزر الباهاما ، هذا هو المكان الذي أحضروا فيه
الضحية الجنود الروس ،
لكن هذه ليست نهاية قصة أندريه
بأعجوبة ، لقد نجا بطريقة ما بعد أن
أمضى الليل مصابًا بجروح بالغة في
الخندق الذي شعرت به وسقطت نظرت حولي
وأدركت أنني كنت أكذب في نوع ما  من
خندق في اليوم التالي وهو يعرج إلى بر الأمان ،
استغرق الأمر 30 أو 40 دقيقة توقفت كثيرًا
لأنني كنت أعاني من ألم شديد ، وما
زال أندريه يعالج من
جروح متعددة بشظايا في الرأس والصدر
والعمود الفقري ، محاولة القتل المزعومة لمدني
أوكراني  في مفترق الطرق هذه ،
مجرد واحدة من مئات
قضايا جرائم الحرب المحتملة التي تحقق فيها الشرطة
في منطقة خاركيف بأوكرانيا ، لكنها
ربما تكون الحادثة الوحيدة التي تم
توثيقها جيدًا بشكل لا يصدق